[Musique]
interactif et réactif voilà les deux
mots d'ordre du nouveau site internet du
conseil départemental du haut rhin
il a été mis en ligne aujourd'hui il
offre un accès direct à tous les
services du département avec notamment
des menus simplifiés organisé par public
le tout accessible sur smartphone et
tablette réaction donc l'esprit du
nouveau site internet du conseil
départemental du haut rhin c'est de se
positionner d'abord au coeur des
préoccupations du citoyen c'est à dire
que c'est le service que recherche le
citoyen qu'il doit pouvoir trouver en
premier on cherche pas à diffuser une
information éditorial une information
politique mais bien à rendre un service
et a contribué à l'efficacité du service
qui est rendue par la collectivité haut
rhinoise le second axe important du site
c'est l'open data donc l'ouverture des
données au public c'est à dire que
l'ensemble au fur et à mesure de la
modernisation des services qu'on a qu'on
a déjà engagé avec ce site mais qui va
continuer avec avec les routes avec les
services sociaux avec les collèges c'est
de mettre à disposition du public que ce
soit des particuliers que ce soit des
autres collectivités ou des entreprises
d information fiable et exacte sur les
services ou les équipements de la
collectivité qui permettront peut-être
demain de produire plus de service ou
même de développer de nouveaux outils de
développement économique
[Musique]